well I'm rather pessimistic but optimism
pessimism I think I have a strong
psychological component that no one
really knows but but but at the moment
it looks as if the destructive
technologies are advancing more rapidly
than the constructive one of the
destructive technologies of course is
burning of fossil fuels that's that's
what's producing global warming it's not
it's not a new technology obviously but
what's new about it is that other new
technologies are enabling tremendous
economic growth in what we used to call
the third world that tremendous economic
growth is contributing to tremendous
increase in the amount of fossil fuel
burning which is creating global warming
and reduction in species diversity and
so on so that's very bad and these just
more overtly destructive technologies
like nuclear which is spreading
obviously proliferating and biological
and I haven't been too much talk about
that recently but in my book and
subsequent thinking the advances in
biotechnology are creating extraordinary
weapon opportunities so within within a
few years it will be possible to
synthesize the smallpox virus which is
the ideal terror weapon and once it's
and once it's synthesized
the the opportunities for actually
weaponizing it become a very great
because there's a huge international
biotechnology industry it's not just the
United States or in the developed world
Brazil for example has a huge biotech
industry so with many thousands of
skilled biologists and bio technicians
all over the world the opportunity for
the smallpox to get into the hands of
some lunatic or some suicidal terrorist
group I think are great and growing and
just you know proliferation of
antibiotics which speed the evolution of
bacteria and viruses right they responds
up to the challenge so you get an
emergence of more dangerous bacteria be
naturally selected to be immune to the
antibiotic so all sorts of dangers lurk
many people are working to try to
contain them but but if you think of the
spread of Baia biological knowledge and
no one is trying to control that so you
know we have we do have theirs there is
government-funded research on trying to
develop new vaccines broad-spectrum
vaccines and so I'm trying to anticipate
possible epidemics either naturally
caused or man caused and try to have but
you know that's a very that's real catch
up type of thing trying to anticipate
all the possible
lethal you know pathogens and developing
vaccines in advance against them an
example of how soon as the problem is to
develop a vaccine against a potential
bio weapon you have to develop the bio
weapon as you make vaccines well so then
you're training all sorts of you know
scientists and how to make a bio weapon
some of them may turn out to be you know
a biological Unabomber and biological
weaponry is much cheaper to create much
easier to create than nuclear which they
know nuclear secrets anymore but there's
no trick to designing the atomic bomb
but the actual the the bottleneck is the
enriched uranium or plutonium and that's
still difficult to come by but but you
don't have that kind of bottleneck in
biological